literally like Christmas guys
I have to show you what I got from TJ Maxx
so first I got jewelry
I'm gonna start with the good things first okay
I got this 14 karat gold ring
these little hoops
basically my mom
when she came to visit
brought me my baby bangles like
which were gold
like from when I was a kid
um and they're like
really cute really small and like
the perfect size for hoop
but I didn't wanna get them like
customized into hoops
didn't wanna ruin them
um so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna put them through here and I'm gonna hang it
and it's gonna be like a little baby bingle as a hoop
and it can be so cute
so I'm gonna show you what I bought and then the things that I left behind
um okay
normally I typically only buy real gold and real silver um
cause I want to last right
however
there's no reality in which I think I can afford this in real gold anytime soon
and I just couldn't pass it up
you're like
it was $13 you know what
I'll take care of them
I'll make sure they don't rust or go bad
I just think they're really pretty
so I had to get them
and I broke my little
you know my little rule
but honestly so worth it
okay I got this for my sister
this is I don't even to um
Urban Outfitters
this is the perfume that they have urban offered
this is the perfume like
line they have Urban Outfitters um
it's only 18 I got it for 13
um my sister
the matcha surprisingly phenomenal scent
she loves it um
so that's for her
I if they had the matcha like
by itself I would have bought it
but you know
whatever I got
I know the food at TJ Maxx is like
very risky um
but I love this brand of chocolate um
and I just wanted to try
so actually we'll try with you
it was originally like
six bucks I paid for like
I paid like five or whatever
nothing crazy
hmm oh wow
hmm good
I got some floss
I just needed some um 4:50
uh
oh my god okay
this I'm so excited about
so this is the cream x onch collab
and fun fact onch is my friend
um uh
I met this group of friends during the pandemic uh
on clubhouse well
places and um
we like
had a discord that we talked literally every single day for
like six months
it was great but um
they are a phenomenal designer
and they had a collab with a cream shop
I'm actually gonna try this one
um and they recently posted about um
their collab at like
being at TJ Maxx
and I was like slay oh
I've never worn one of these
oh
I have a big head
is it giving I can't see
okay cool
I got a makeup headband love slay
lust so soft it literally has their name and their thing is like uh
the pretzel they make like pretzel jewelry
pretzel like clay
um anyways
so this is anches little light
I'm so excited about it
um case for my AirPods honestly
cause I've been raw dogging I um
my like old pair
I like lost one of the
oh shit okay calm down
um
just plain black
uh I wish this was silver
but cute slay awesome
cool glossier bomb dot com
the new one what
oh I took him so long
I wish this was like um
like a actual
like color
something smells and taste like literally nothing exactly as I remember it
yeah I wouldn't buy this again
um I still like it maybe
okay I got this Urban Decay Naked Mini Palette I'm really excited about um
it was $7
slow
yes watch
oh you know what
while we're here should I
cute okay
love this can give this my bag
I got this YSL gloss hello
so happy about this
it's red it's a little bright for me
hmm
cute it's a little light
I would definitely wear this with a
oh my god it's a little lip shut up
shut up that's so cute
okay um
this obviously needs like a liner or something
but love smells good too
love that it's a little like hmm
watery
I think it's intentional
but I don't know why
my lips blushed again because I'm looking pale
this Clinique Black Honey gloss
let's see how it looks on me
yeah
and you know
I don't love the way my lips look without liner when I put on colored gloss
but cute
um I like that little
cute
love this oh
my god I love the gloss that I got
okay um
I got this from mom
my mom like
is obsessed with these shoes
like this specific brand
it's like a like
Clark's knockoff
not knockoff it's like a Clark's brand
and they're like sandals
and my mom love
she lives in Florida
so this is like
what she wears literally every day
and it comes from red
I'm putting I'm pushing a red agenda on my family
who actually has red hair
so technically she pushed it first
and she's from
and she grew up during Zoe Union in Eastern Europe
so she's actually the one who pushed the red agenda first
um but my mom
like now doesn't really wear a lot of color except her hair
but I'm like okay
you need these
so I got these for her
a little big for her
but she got them
and then I got my sister
oh and those were $27
I forgot saying the prices these
tell me tell me
tell me
these are Steve Madden shoes for my sister
40 bucks I'm a phenomenal sister because these are so cute
got this just this
like regular rose oil um
body wash I
if you didn't know
love rose I love rose and I love rose scent and Bulgarian
so rose is a very big deal
and this smells specifically like Bulgarian rose
which is why I bought it um
I'm really susceptible to buying basically literally anything with rose
speak of the devil
I got um
these rose um
makeup wipes cause I know makeup wipes bad
blah blah blah
but like you know I needed
oh did I not buy
oh I left some things I didn't wanna leave okay
I have this rose perfume
I don't have any like
regular cheap perfume that I could like
have with me um
and this smells really good
it was like 10 bucks
so it was on clearance
um I got this so that I can dry brush
got this cause we were out of hand soap
I got this cause I was out of awesome
see you I can't believe I found this here awesome
so I'm showing you
this is so I'm so glad I found this
beautiful scents and it was only $13
don't mind if I do
these are definitely the start of the show for me though
the black honey
I've been wanting to get a color YSL
need I say more
I'll see you love um
I'm literally so happy with this haul
amazing phenomenal
so good and these are the things that I didn't end up actually getting like
a boob syrup the Garnier Fructis Kylie Skin Lip Matte Morot Supergoop
I would have gotten this if it was my skin tone
oh I forgot what it's called
beauty of josine
that Korean brand that's like
all over TikTok
I do own things from them
yes and this Sephora
like two dollar clearance thing
I don't think any of this was like necessary